73 ще особисте послання Петра Порошенка я
до президента України
та парламенту про внутрішню та сонячну
ситуацію power мене донбасу та криму
весь кого-кого вирішення проблеми
цілісності україни навісний краще при
такий дипломатичний прикольний президент
не виступає за збереження нормандського
формату переговорів порошенка за
повністю конституцію часті немає
децентралізації на зраді dota dota русі
я не ви кунаї положення мінських догляд
рахунки донбасом засіки право володіння
російських whiskas акопова знайти
риторики та праведного ні українського
контролю над українським кордоном
президента куш вигляд повивши на його
путіна просто шукаю харчування криму не побуту
закритим порошенком погода вся ця акція
харчування закритий ще 90 porsche уроку
кулінар френдами жителі криму
проголосували за незалежність україни у
барона чекати немає україни за словами
президента українська армія вже знатно
завести ти україну вигляд російської
агресії нібито сир цьому вона була у
такому стане, а зелені чоловічки не
сунулася апу крим і на донбасі не було
з російських віз і як заявив
порошенка україна сварт пеклам з цього
партнерів за треба ньяма летальну зброю
у рази повномасштабну повторну русі та
україна і чи треба вимагатиме серйозні
міжнародні петренко буде без
російську агресію на те і базис
президент підтвердив ступ донату
завищується стратегічну ми і
україни в 1 годину порошенка застосовуватися та
процеси з сенсорними 2 ремейки можете
навіщо ти себе за це ризикового на
ближньому глава держави заклеювання в роботи
і виводжу не крокусу будинок лю чичі в
альянсі th nemo і телиця в цій галузі
ще до членства України + його
президентів коришся у сни україна 3
травня б за візовий режим з
соціально-економічна ситуація
порошенку за залучені пропустіть
бюджет на нас тут на річці ще там буде
з косово не стипендії президента кузові
вся Україна витрачала 15 мільярдів
доларів вид закриття російського ринку
для українських товарів і назвавши цим актом
економічної агресії та у днів з
причин падіння ременя жити українців
боротьба з корупцією
президент прикутий ще довідкові
поливання на корупціонерів вже патча
лося та й благо і cool
на бій з бутом vs поставили на
корупціонерів рухайся безпрецедентно
шведському у тебе порошенка по передавши ще
для боротьби з корупцією не добитися від
деколь караоке